المنصف المرزوقي رئيس التونسيه السابق
السيد المنصف المرزوقي مرحبا بك معنا
حلما طموحا وباتا واقعا معاشا ملموسا
بجاهزيه عاليه كيف تنظر الى هذا الانجاز
الذي ارادته قطر ان يكون لها وللعرب
اليوم قطر هي المكان الوحيد الذي يشعرون
به في الفرح في بحر الفشل العربي النجاح
المقاطع وبالتالي انا اريد يعني الاسم
الخاص
شكرا
يعني الغربيه يعني من بعض الاطراف خاصه عن
بعض الصحف على على هذه التجربه
واتذكره هناك كلمه السيد المسيح الذي يقول
يرون يعني القشه في عيون الاخرين ولا يرون
العمود الذي في اعينهم
اذا في شخص يعني يعرف ازدواجات الخطاب في
في البلدان الغربيه هو انا يعني عيشت كيف
يدافعون دوما على الديمقراطيه وكيف يدعمون
بكل وقاحه يعني الاستبداد العربي في كل
مكان واخ النسخه ما يقع اليوم في بلده
للاسف الشديد همم هم ايضا يعني في هذه
الهجمه التي يعني انا اشعر بها كان هاشم
بدي انا شخصيا يعني كعربي يعني شغل يعني
ما عندكش الفكر على الفضاء التي اراها
اليوم في الصحف خاصه في الصحف الموجوده في
اوروبا يعني
واضح انه عنده مشكله اساسيه انه يصير فيه
نجاح باهر في دوله عربيه مسلمه وواضح انهم
ايضا يريدون ان يغني تحقق القطريين انا
ادرى الناس ايضا يعني عندي يعني لحسن الحظ
الاصدقاء من الداخل والله عايش يعني همم
كم تحاول السلطات همم كم حاولت وكم تحاول
يعني اصله القطريه ان تكون هذه همم يعني
هذه الحفله لا تكون على حساب الفقراء على
حساب المسكين في 2014 انا اعلم انه المجلس
الاعلى القطري يعني وضع خطوط عامه
للمحافظه على صحه العمال انا اعلم انه في
2017 همم الغيت الوكاله انا اعلم انه في
2020 يعني صارت في هناك العديد
يعني همم القوانين المعدله لكي تحفظ كرامه
وحقوق العمال في 2021 انا اعلم انه ايضا
صار فيه همم رفع المستوى الداخل لهؤلاء
العمال الى اخره ومع هذا كل هذا العمل
الجبار الذي تقوم به الاداره السياسيه لم
يره اصحابنا هنا في الغرب ويركز على نواقص
وهذه النواقف موجوده في كل العمل البشري
وهم قدر الناس يعرفون انه في كل البلدان
التي فيها الاقتصاد الليبرالي الاراده
السياسيه تصطدم دائما وابدا بما تقوم به
الشركات التي تماطل او تحاول او كذا واعلم
انه الاداره السياسيه في في قطر فعل اجبار
هذه الشركات على حق احترام حقوق العمل
وبالتالي انا اعتبر ان هذه الهجمه القذره
التي موجوده ضد قطر مرفوضه جمله خاصه تاتي
من هؤلاء الناس المعروفين بالزواج السيد
موسى
همم هذا الحدث بهذه الجاهزيه او بهذه
الروح الجامعه
على الانسانيه
ستؤثر وتغير من حاله التنميط لصوره العرب
التي حاول بعض دعنا نقول بعض الدول
الغربيه ولا نجمعهم جميعا ان يرسخوها الى
الان في الاذهان
نوع من الغيره يعني هناك واضح انه غير
يعني كثير من الدول وليس فقط من الدول
الغربيه لنجاح دوله عربي مسلمه ولنجاح قطر
وخاصه
يعلمون انه همم قطر تعود على ذاتها تعود
على طاقاتها الى اخره وهم لا يريدون في
الواقع للاسف الشديد النجاح لبلدان وتميز
قطر في الوقت الحاضر يجعلهم يراجعون كل
همم كل افكارهم حول تفوقهم والمزعوم لاني
واضح انه همم يعني مدن المستقبل وحركات
المستقبل لم تعود موجوده فقط في الغرب
موجوده ايضا في كل مكان مره اخرى انا
اعتبر انه ما يقع اليوم هو التشجيع لكل
بلدان العالم الثالث تشجيع للعرب وللمسلم
ان نحن نستطيع ان نقوم بكل المعجزات
نستطيع ان نتغلب على كل العقبات لانه في
ضرب في 10 سنوات يعني انظر ما فعلته قطر
وانا اعتبره انه فعلا هناك درس لا يجب ان
تتعلم منه كل الشعوب وهو انه الاراده
السياسيه والذكاء وليس فقط الامكانيات
الماديه لا نكثير من البلدان لها امكانيه
الماديه واكثر من الامكانيات الماديه الى
عندها قطر لكن عندما تكون هناك الذكاء
ونعتبر ان هناك كثير من الذكاء وهنا
الكثير من الاراده السياسيه الصائبه
الباشا بالاتجاه الصحيح نفعل هذه المعجزات
ويعني بماذا تدلل شهاده رئيس الاتحاد
الدولي لكره القدم اليوم جاني انفانتينو
الذي همم يعني علق وقال عن هذه الهجمه
بانها دروس اخلاقيه تنوم عن النفاق وتحدث
عن معايير مزدوجه برايك ما هي الدلاله
الرئيسيه لمثل هذا التوصيل
هناك اعتقد انه في كثير من العنصريه
ثقافيه التي مازالت متغلله هناك كثير من
الحسد هناك كثير من الغيره مره اخرى ليست
هناك ادنى مصداقيه لاني مثل ما قلت لك انا
اعرف الخطاب ازدواجيه الخطاب في السياسه
يتحدثون عن الديمقراطيه اخرى يعني يمارسون
او يدعمون الاستبداد والديكتاتوريه في كل
مكانها يعني سنتعلم وسنتها لانه مره اخرى
بالعكس احنا من هذه يعني الضغط الممارسه
علينا المنافسه ستكون هي همم
منافس بقوه ان شاء الله القطري الان يؤخر
في في كثير من البلدان العربيه وليس فقط
لا مره اخرى مش قضيه ماده هناك كثير من
البلدان موجوده عندها ماده اسال عند
لاراده السياسيه ولا ذكاء السياسي اللي
يخلي قطر اليوم تفتح طريق يعني للامه
اعتبر انه طريق همم طريق الامل السياسه